في الكويت وفي اقل من سنه تم تكليف الشيخ
احمد نواف الاحمد الصباح بتولي رئاسه
الوزراء وتشكيل الحكومه للمره الثالثه فقد
اعلنت وكاله الانباء الكويتيه صدور امر
اميري بتعين الشيخ احمد النواف رئيسا
لمجلس الوزراء كما تضمن الامر تكليفه
بترشيح اعضاء الحكومه الجديده
من الكويت ينضم الينا الدكتور سعد بن طفله
وزير الاعلام الاسبق دكتور سعد حياك الله
معي في نشره الرابعه من الرياض بدايه
كيف تنظر لاعاده تسميه الشيخ احمد النواف
رئيسا لمجلس الوزراء الكويتي وهل كان
متوقعا
احييكم مشاهديكم وكل عام وانتم بقناه
العربيه بخير
يعني المتابع للشان الكويتي كان يدرك بان
سيعيد تكليف سمو الشيخ احمد النواف رئيس
الوزراء وبالتالي فلا مفاجاه يعني شاع
هناك بان الدكتور محمد صباح السالم يعني
شعبي مواقع التواصل ربما بعض الصحف يعني
بانه هو من سيتولى رئاسه الوزراء او من
سيكلف بتشكيل هذه الحكومه الجديده
الشاعر لدي مثل ما شاع لديكم يعني بانه
فعلا طلب منه او انه قد كلف ربما برئاسه
الوزراء السابقه ولكنه اعتذر وقيل بان
السبب هو اشتراط يعني صلاحيات كامله فيما
يتعلق برئاسه الوزراء هذا ما تم يعني
تداول في وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي
وحينها يعني كانوا الناس يعني يعملون بان
يكون الدكتور محمد صباح السالم خريج هارب
حسين الوزراء ولكن ذلك لم يتم اليوم طبيعه
العلاقه بين المجلس والحكومه دكتور سعيد
اعاده تسميه الشيخ نواف مره اخرى اعاده
تشكيل الحكومه هل تعتقد بان هذه الطبيعه
لهذه العلاقه تعيدنا دائما لنفس المربع
الاول
كم كان بيودي يا صديقي ان اكون متفائلا
على الاقل ككويتي ولكن على الاقل كمراقب
في قناتكم يعني الان من خلال قناتكم لابد
ان اكون موضوعي واقع الحال يقول بان هناك
درجه عاليه جدا من التراجع للاسف الشديد
في حاله التفاؤل التي سادت بالعهد الجديد
بعد خطاب 22 يونيو السنه الماضيه جاءت
الانتخابات بدرجه عاليه من النزاهه ولكن
ايضا هذه الانتخابات ايضا مطعون بعض
نتائجها ومنظور في نتائجها امام المحكمه
الدستوريه لا اريد ان اقول اكثر من ذلك
يعني التزاما بالقانون لا تعليق لا تنتهي
محكمه الدستوريه من النظر في هذه الطعون
ومن ثم نحن امام يعني
الذي لم يستطع التعامل مع البرلمان السابق
هذا البرلمان الان يواجه ربما بعض الطعون
التي قد تؤدي لا اعرف لا اعرف القراءات
المختلفه ولكن بعض المتهمين يذهبون الى حل
البرلمان واخرين يقولون اعاده الانتخابات
في بعض الدوائر او الغاء نتائجها
الى الدواليب اريد ان اخلص اللي
ل ولا يزال هناك
اكثر شاغر في الكويت وهذا يدل على شيء يدل
على يعني تراجع لداري في الاداره السياسيه
من قبل الحكومات السابقه وبعض هذه المناصب
مهمه جدا مثل مدير جامعه جامعه الكويت مثل
رئيس اركان مثل وزير دفاع اصلي مثل نائب
رئيس اركان وهكذا يعني الناس الحقيقه تشعر
بعدم يعني
بلا تفاؤل خلني ما اقول الكلمه اقوى دكتور
سعد خليني اسالك سؤال يمكن
موجود في دين كل احد يتابعنا الان لماذا
دائما تعود الكويت لذات المربع لماذا
دائما يعني تعود الكويت لحل الحكومه وبعد
ذلك تعيين حكومه تصريف اعمال وتعود
الحكومه وبعد ذلك المواجهه في مجلس الامه
النواب يواجهون الحكومه يتم استجواب
الوزراء استفزاز هذه الحكومه ثم تقديم
الاستقاله بعد ذلك ويعني هذا سيناريو
متكرر للمره الثالثه يعني في اقل من سنه
يعاد تشكيل هذه الحكومه ويعني نحن نتحدث
عن فتره سنه واحده فقط يعني 12 شهرا ثلاث
حكومات
يعني ما هو الخلل يا دكتور او ما هو الحل
لهذا الوضع الموجود اليوم في الكويت
واسع من التعبير عن الراي ربما مليون ونصف
حل يعني هذه طبيعه الاشياء يعني الدول
التي تتمتع بها مش يعني واسع من حريه
التعبير لكن انا ممكن اقول لك رايي
المتواضع يعني اننا نعيد نفس التجربه بنفس
الادوات ونتوقع نتائج مختلفه انا شخصيا
اعتقد بانه لا يمكن ان يكون سواء سمو
الشيخ احمد النواف او حتى الدكتور محمد
صباح السالم لو اتى رئيس الحكومه يمكن ان
يكون هناك تعاون بين السلطتين في ظ اتخاذ
القرار الحاليه التي تشكل يشكل فيها مجلس
الامه 50 مجلس امه خمسين برلمان كل نائب
يشك برلمان بحد ذاته ويعطي مثل ما تفضلت
ربما يعني صلاحيات واسعه للنواب على حساب
مثلا سلطه كامله ممثله بالسلطه التنفيذيه
والعكس تماما لكن لا نريد ايضا يعني كثير
مثلا المراقبين
الخاصه هذا التعاون وهذه المسيره في الوقت
الذي ذكرت لك مثال على سبيل المثال 500
موقع قيادي
في البلد يعني ما اعت
قد ليش ما تعين وزير الدفاع ولا ما تعين
رئيس اركان ولا مدير جامعه الكويت ما راح
يوقف
انا اعتقد بان مجلس الامه يمكن ان يعوق
احيانا ان يعطل احيانا مثل ما نقول بالشعب
احيانا لكن ليس هو السبب في المشكله بين
السلطتين من السبب يا دكتور
اقول لك راي متواضع يعني كمراقب ولكن ايضا
كمواطن يعني لاني من 2012 انا قاطعت
الانتخابات ولا ازال واعتقد بان السير
بهذه الطريقه بهذا الشكل سينتج ويعيدنا
الى المربع الاول مره اخرى لاننا كما ذكرت
لك يعني تقصد بان هذه العمليه السياسيه
اليوم يا دكتور في الكويت لم تعد صالحه
لهذا الوقت لهذا الزمان وهكذا شكل سياسي
يعني حتى غير غير مفيد للكويت نفسها وانا
اللي اقول شذي المؤسسون الذين وضعوا دستور
عام 1962 توقعوا له خمس سنوات ثم يعني
يعدل هذا الدستور لاليه اكثر ديناميكيه
نحن لازمنا نراوح على مدرسه
بهذا الدستور واعتقد بانه امن الاواني الى
ان يكون في اليه عصريه وحديثه وعمليه لخلق
اجواء واليه اتخاذ قرار طيب دكتور ايضا
هناك سؤال فيما يخص هذه الحكومه الجديده
ماذا لو اعيد تسميه وزراء كانوا موجودين
بالفعل في الحكومه السابقه او حتى وزراء
كانوا من الوزراء الذين طلب استجوابهم في
مجلس الامه كيف تتوقع حيكون المشهد يعني
هذا جزء من المعضل الحقيقه ان اي لاعب
ممكن يعترض على يعني تعيين وزراء اعتقد
بانه يعني من ضعف الحكومات التي توالت على
السلطه التنفيذي يعني رئيس الوزراء يفترض
ان يكون ممثل للسلطه يعني هي موازيه
السلطه التشريعيه على الاقل دستوريه مع
سلفه القضائيه وراسها سمو الامير لكن يعني
بعض
الحكومه متردده وخائفه وخائفه من البرلمان
ولا اعرف لماذا يعني بس في نفس الوقت اذا
كنت اعتقد بانك ستاتي بنواب سيرضى عنهم كل
الناس فانا
تماما مثل ما لم يرضى الناس بوجود بعض
الاعضاء او ربما بالنسبه لمعظم الاعضاء
الموجو الامه اليوم ولكن هذا هو ما اختاره
الناس وفي نفس الوقت يجب ان نقدر بان
اختيار
هو حق دستوري
نفس الوقت من حق رئيس الوزراء ان يشكل
حكومته كما يرى بالمدينه يعني يترجمون
برنامج هل
هناك ولم ارى شيئا طيب حتى يعني تشكل هذه
الحكومه ان شاء الله تكون معنا دكتور سعد
نناقش ايضا هذه الرؤيه او البرنامج
الحكومي ان تم الاعلان عنه في قادم الايام
من الكويت دكتور سعد بن طفله وزير الاعلام
الاسبق شكرا جزيلا